I'd like to take a moment and
show you the process of
creating an object diagram.
You might also hear this process
referred to as object decomposition.
That is, we're taking something
that's a big object, like an app,
and we're breaking it down into
its individual components.
Now, there's no right or
wrong way to do this.
If 100 people create
an object diagram for an app,
there might be 100 completely
different diagrams.
Also there are some informal and
formal ways to create them.
A formal way might be creating an object
diagram using the universal modeling
language or UML.
And an example object diagram's
given here on the left.
Now UML as a modeling language contains
a bunch of standard symbols and
icons that are helpful for
laying out the components of a project.
But for many UML can be
really bulky to work with.
And I fall into that category.
I'm more of a fan of an informal
approach that takes some ideas from UML,
but it doesn't get bogged down
in the nitty gritty details.
And an example of a more informal object
diagram is given here on the right.
So for this example,
I'm going to take an app that you'll
see later called Alien Adventure.
This is the main screen for the app and
I can interact with it by
tapping on the screen.
And we can see that this robot
will animate across the screen and
there's an alien.
There's actually multiple aliens,
and the robot and
the alien will have a discussion and
will go back and forth.
And if the robot answers the aliens
question correctly then these little
badges will appear in the lower
left hand corner of the screen.
I'm going to stop right here.
At this point, we've already seen
enough of this app to actually start
the object decomposition process.
So I'm going to open a Google
drawing to build the diagram.
But you could use a piece of paper,
a napkin,
a tool like draw.io, which I have that
opened up in this other tab here.
This is a draw io diagram or really just
any tool that gives you the ability
to put your ideas into a diagram.
Personally, I'm a big fan of napkins and
then I can say from personal experience
that a lot of great ideas
I've diagrammed on napkins.
Idling to say that there's probably some
other amazing apps out there that have
been diagramed on napkins but,
that's a different story.
The first thing will start with
is the first big object which is
the app itself.
Now, the app is an actual object and
code but that's okay.
We're going to use that
as our starting point and
if we think about what we saw when
you're playing around with the app,
we can start adding those
objects to the diagram.
So we know that there's a robot and
that there were aliens, so
I'm going to go ahead make some
rectangles to represent those and
we'll add labels for
the robot object and the alien object.
You'll notice that I'm using the
singular form of alien and not aliens,
even though there are multiple
aliens in the app
if we were to continue playing it.
And this is a personal preference,
and it's one of those aspects of UML
that I'm blending with
this informal approach.
In UML you typically refer to
objects in their singular form.
Also if I was using a more
formal process I might use
a certain type of symbol for
an object, maybe a rectangle and
then a certain type of symbol for
a struct like a rounded rectangle.
But again because we're
keeping it pretty informal,
I'm just going to use rectangles for
everything.
Now what else did we notice in the app?
What else seemed to stand out in our
mind as a self-contained entity?
What else could be considered
part of the application.
Some of the things that I can
think of are the background.
We also had badges that appeared
in the lower left hand corner.
And there was a dialogue
bubble at the top and
it consisted of multiple lines of text.
This is a pretty good set
of objects to start with.
These were all things that we
could clearly see with our eyes.
But there could also be objects
that are behind the scenes.
Things that we can't see, but still make
up some part of the application itself.
For example,
what about the concept of a game world.
Maybe the aliens, the robot and
everything within it could be
thought as parts of a game world.
So I'm going to go ahead and add a
symbol for world to our object diagram.
In adding world here is just another
example of what I really want to
stress to you.
This process is not exact science.
It's a very creative abstract
thinking type of process.
No two people probably create
the same object diagram.
Now, I'm going to go ahead stop here.
In just a moment we're
going to refine this diagram.
We're going to think about how
the objects are interconnected and
we're also going to look to see if any
of the objects have similarities because
that's a big deal when designing apps.
That some of the objects share traits
and other similar functionality,
then we can take advantage of that
later when we start writing code.